so my first question for you because
this
is not your first christmas movie what
draws you to them in general
um this is kind of a joke now it was an
inside joke and now it's kind of out
there i didn't grow up with christmas
i never had a christmas i grew up my
mom's jewish so i grew up in a jewish
household
and i never had a christmas tree we
never i
santa claus was never real to me because
i was told that he didn't exist
you know it was just so i think a lot of
it is probably my mom's fault
because i've been so deprived
from christmas that i'm like i can do a
christmas movie and it can be christmas
every day for six weeks and
you know it's it's uh i won't say it's a
bit of a problem
um i'm trying to curb how many i do
but i love christmas i mean i
love it so um but the script has to be
there like it can't be
i'm still like a little of a different
kind of bird so i still need to make
sure that it has
something that it elevates um women
in some way or elevate elevates black
women like it has to have
something there to make it make sense
for me to do it
um but christmas is definitely uh
something that i love to do
um all the time you're making me
appreciate the fact that i at least
grew up with a hanukkah bush so i was
able to talk thank you
yes the hanukkah bush i'm like grandma
what is that it's a hanukkah bush
it looks like a i think that's a
christmas tree now annika bush
setting it up this week the the game is
on in this house come on
it's on sheckles dreidels let's go
so i know this movie is based on a real
military drop but are there any smaller
true details that you're really hoping
viewers pick up on
you know somebody who i think would be
surprised that i'm even mentioning him
right now his name is brother bruce he's
been
a huge reason that the drop happens
every year
and he goes uh
all over to make sure that it all comes
together he's the real santa claus and
he's really
the mvp to me so that's that's a little
he's in the film um and he's one of the
most
humble amazing brilliant loving and
giving selfless people i've ever met
and he's real he's not some character
written in the script
that just makes a quick cameo he's a
real person
and people like that exist like they
exist
and so you know it makes you want to
like pull up and just do better and give
more and be more present
and be more loving because he's just the
real deal
i might have been googling him like
crazy after watching the movie
yes yeah he's he's amazing i saw him and
i hadn't seen the movie before and i did
a watch party with the fans and he came
on the screen
and i tell you i started to cry like i
was like oh my god i'm crying on camera
again
like but it was i didn't even care
because he's just so amazing he's just
that special he really i'm also mighty
curious about your experience filming in
guam
what is something specific to the
production process
there that you have yet to experience
anywhere else well they never shot a
movie in guam before
like we were the first and it felt like
it like we
were we made it all work and everyone
came together from the anderson air
force base to the locals like
they pulled it together for us
i love being hot i am you know my mom's
jewish but my dad is african i love my
heat
um but that it got hot it got real
hot and i turned into larry david a
couple times
and i was schvitzing a lot but i had a
fantastic time and we were able we had a
lot of support
um we had a great medic that was making
sure that everyone was not passing out
and it was just it was phenomenal we
were so supported and we were so
protected and
everyone came together like the most
incredible team
to make this movie what it turned out to
be for sure
what about filming on an active air
force base because when i read that
for your sound department in particular
i don't understand how that works
well i'm glad they didn't quit on us um
because there were times where alex and
i
looked at each other like we're just
gonna have to adr this whole scene like
there's a full
jet flying over us it's like us having a
conversation
and like multiple jets flying in
every direction and you know lieutenants
and people calling out
things and you know it was intense
it was intense like i remember watching
i think it was like the actor's corner
something with jim carrey and they asked
him what acting is like and it's like
well it's like acting
you know like acting class but you just
have a bunch of tennis balls being
thrown at you all the time
this was that times a thousand and i am
so easily entertained anyways i was like
like i was like really enthralled by
everything
um but we actually got a movie done and
it came out great
so that's the point and we're not going
to get in the way of the air force
that's what we're not going to do
not get in the way but did you get the
opportunity to actually experience
flying
yeah they took us up in a c130 i believe
that's what it's called don't quote me
but i do think it's called a c-130
and in jets and the navy took us up in a
helicopter that by the way
had no door um
and that was really amazing uh they they
took
us everywhere they they made sure that
we had everything we needed
to make this authentic and it was it was
sometimes like really authentic uh but i
appreciated all of it because it's an
experience i don't know i'll ever have
that experience again
you know what i mean now i have to
follow up what is an example of a time
when it got
really authentic um the
the air force um they're bad asses
especially the women and uh one of the
pilots
she uh did a couple cool moves
um that uh and while we were in the air
and uh alex of course was like yeah
and it was one of those kind of moments
where it's like i was like on the
ceiling it felt like
um but it was so cool and we were so
grateful
for their time and their badassery
it made me definitely look at myself
and say what are you doing um
yeah they were amazing so i wanted to
end on an unrelated question because i
was reading
what you said recently about wearing
wigs and not changing your look
unless a roll absolutely called for it
and i think it's important to speak up
about those things but i think speaking
up about them can be scary for some
folks out there
so what are some actionable lessons or
approaches that you put to use on the
projects that you work on that might
help someone else out
i think it's about having conversations
about having honest conversations about
being honest with yourself and who you
are and not trying to
to you know a lot of us especially if
you're an actress or you're an
entertainment
you kind of almost have this disease to
please because there's like so much
rejection
in hollywood when you finally do get
that role or you are able to be a part
of a project
you just don't want to ruffle any
feathers you know especially if you are
the only one of your
kind if you are the only black person or
the asian person or lgbtqia character
you know you really want to sometimes
fall in line
and i think that there's a way to be
respectful but also
challenge um something stylistically
visually that might in a way
elevate people's consciousness or their
awareness you know for me
i'm already as you i think know from
this interview i grew up different
i'm just a little different and i think
i spent a lot of time
kind of hiding that or wearing maybe
what other people thought i should wear
or doing my hair
in a way that i thought other people
should wear and i finally gave
came to this point of a like self-love
and
um that has to translate and i and i
think that there are times where
characters call for straight hair or
curly hair or an afro or i want to wear
my hair and curls or whatever it is
but these have to be honest
conversations about why people
executives or writers are making certain
decisions
for characters and i'm now more
comfortable having uncomfortable
conversations
because they need to be had because we
want to talk about love and we want to
talk about acceptance and we want to
talk about
diplomacy and we want to talk about all
those things
but unfortunately there's not enough
diversity
in hollywood and when you and when
you're able to really showcase
you know different kinds of people on
screen that translates into how people
relate to each other in the real world
um and i think that that's really what
it's about it's about how we treat each
other
um and there's there's no more
discrimination and there's no more
racism and everyone really accepts each
other for
for who they are but we have to come as
who we are first
absolutely i appreciate your voice in
that department and again huge
congratulations on this movie it is so
much